hey guys i'm ijustine and the big day
has finally arrived for me to announce
the winners of my mass canvas design
contest for charity water now last month
i asked you guys to submit a design in
the theme of fluidity you guys rose to
the challenge we had over 150
submissions now it's time to reveal the
five winners that will each win a
thousand dollars and whose designs will
be available as a one-time only
collector's edition t-shirt
gene yat mcnamara go with the flow now i
really love the way that you gave a
personality to the ice cube and this
little puddle counterpart so cute like
krisa technical owl i absolutely love
this design it's super simple techy and
it definitely looks amazing on a t-shirt
but you say so myself
snowpop infinite glow this is also one
of my favorite submissions now i love
the illustration and i can't wait to
wear this on the t-shirt and i'm going
to wear it proudly tell you
rex y'all fluid anatomy this is a great
design and it's a great example of
fluidity flowing through the illustrated
little intestinal pipe finally again
mike frieza a drop of light now i love
this t-shirt design because it really
shows that the heart of everything from
video games to life in general without
water none of it would be possible so
congratulations mike
for every five thousand dollars charity
water builds well in a place with clean
water sometimes as far as a four hour
walk away and rather than being able to
go to school or do all the fun things
that we get to do growing up children
often spend days walking to and from a
water source just trying to keep their
families alive charity water changes
those lives by building wells and water
projects that bring fresh water to these
remote places and this is something
really important that we can all help in
for every 2 500 shirts of these amazing
winning designs we sell we will
collectively built one well and affected
hundreds of lives and our goal is to
build two wells as a special treat for
anyone who buys in the first 24 hours
we'll be selecting five special winners
to win the first t-shirt out of the
thousand shirts that'll be framed and
signed by me so hurry up guys it all
starts now at facebook.com masscampus
congratulations to all of the winners
again and stay tuned for the special
winners and updates on all of our well
building thanks guys bye
oh you dropped the brush
my mask
canvas
sorry let's screw it up
drop your t-shirts
sorry
part of everything from video from video
games oh geez sorry special winners
i screwed up right at the end right at
the end
i got really scared
sorry
sorry that's entertaining